bu insanlar için öleceksin Bir de hiç
tanımadığın insanlar için hem de kimse
seni buna zorlamadan ver Ver Nazım
birbirimize o kadar çok ihtiyacımız var
ki bir araya gelerek dayanışma içinde bu
memleketin aydınlık geleceği için Omuz
Omuza çalışmaya O yüzden şu son yıllarda
da Kooperatifler çok fazla konuşulmaya
başladı çünkü işte aydınlık Gelecekte
bizi bir araya getirecek en güzel
yapılar neden en güzel yapılar hem
ekonomik Hem de sosyal anlamda bizleri
gerçekten güçlendirecek bir yapıyı çünkü
sizin düşünün Bu salonda Hepimizin bir
avuç zeytin olabilir
bu bizim bir avuç zeytin Biz en fazla
bir kavanoza Tuzla'ya biliriz işte ondan
sonra yiyebiliriz ama onun daha
fazlasını yapabilmemiz için mu salondaki
herkesin O bir avuç Zeytinli bir araya
getirip Fabrikaya gidip sıktığımızda bir
zeytinyağına sahip olabiliriz işte
tarımsal Kalkınma Kooperatifleri Bu
memleketin çok daha öncesinde 1800'lerde
başlamış bir hareket ve inanılmış bir
ekonomik 3 lenme dayanışma mezoli modeli
1800'lerde Mithatpaşa o zaman Osmanlı
toprakları Sırbistan'da hem özgürlük
hareketi'nin hem de demokratikleşme
hareketinin öncülerinden ve
kooperatifleşmenin ve yaygınlaşmasını
sağlayan bir Paşa kendi Ömür vefat
etmemiş ama Mithatpaşa Ziraat
Bankası'nın kurucularından öncüsüdür
bizim için neden önemlidir Aslında bu
toprakların genlerinde ne zaman
başladığını anlatmak istiyorum size
Mithatpaşa mesleki
bu İzmirli seyircilerimiz belirler
Mithatpaşa Meslek lisesinden sonra
Mithatpaşa Caddesi'nden devam edersiniz
ama o Cadde yatan başladığınızda İşte bu
büstü görebilirsiniz Mithatpaşa Biz de
oradan selamını verir Ama bu topraklarda
hem teorik hem de uygulamanın bir arada
uygun getirildiği dönem öncesinde ta
İşte bu yoldan kooperatifleşme yolunda
incir üreticilerinin onları köşeye
sıkıştıran bazı tüccarlara karşı bu üç
ve efendi Aydın'da bir araya gelirler ve
incir müstahsilleri oluştururlar ve şuan
günümüze kadar gelen bu elinin bereketli
topraklarında Hala biz tarihle
müstahsilleri nizle kendinizi
kalkındırmak için bir kooperatif çatısı
altında beraber çalışabiliyor Uz fakat
Tariş Tabi o dönem
Hem de ne yazık ki yönetimlerin biraz
zorlamasıyla bazı yoldan çıkmalara
sebebiyet verse de tarihten sonra o
1900'lerden sonra dediğim gibi teori ve
uygulamayı buluşturan Mustafa Kemal
Atatürk'tür Çünkü o kadar büyük bir adam
ki 1920'de daha meşru kurulmadan önce
Mustafa Kemal kooperatif şirketler
kanunu hazırlamış ve meclis kurulur
kurulmaz da bunu gündeme getireceğim
demiş 77 madde Tabii hiçbir şey kolay
olmuyor bu memlekette Mustafa Kemal'in o
meclis kurulduktan sonra getirdiği 77
madde Sadece 5 maddesi kabul görmüş
Benim de önünü açan bana ışık tutan
Mustafa Kemal'in birçok ışık tutan
yolundan biridir o 5. madde aynen şöyle
demiş Mustafa Kemal köylerdeki
ziraatçılar
bu memurlar ve öğretmenler
kooperatifçiliğin yaygınlaşması
kooperatifleşmenin kurulmasıyla mesuldür
şimdi Tabi o dönemlerde Cumhuriyet
döneminde Mustafa Kemal bütün köylerde
okullar kuruluyor köylere öğretmenler
gidiyor ve tarıma o kadar önemsiyor ki
aynı zamanda da öğretmenlere bu görevi
veriyor 1934 lere doğru Mustafa Kemal
Saffet Arıkan'ın çağırır der ki bütün bu
devrimleri yaptık Ama biz köylüye bunu
ulaştırıyoruz başka bir şey yapmamız
lazım köyler öğretmenleri daha çok
göndermemiz lazım askerde öğretmenlik
eğitimi alan çavuşları tekrar köylerine
öğretmen olarak görevlendirilenler ve
İşte o dönemde Köy Enstitüleri'nin artık
temelleri atılmış olur
bu Mustafa Kemal vefatından sonra adlı
projeye İbrahim Hakkı Tonguç İsmail
Hakkı Tonguç rehberlik ediyor fakat
sonrasında Mustafa Kemal'in vefatından
sonra Milli Eğitim Bakanı Hasan Ali
Yücel bunun sadece bir öğretmendir
eğitim meselesi olmadığını Aynı zamanda
da bir tarım reformu yapılması
gerektiğini söyler ve ülke 21 tarım
bölgesine ayrılarak ülkenin her tarafına
öğretmenler hem köylüye itmeye ama aynı
zamanda da tarımı güçlendirmeye şimdi bu
haritaya baktığımız zaman o dönemde
nasıl bir aydınlanma yaşadığını köy
enstitülerine köylerin ne kadar kitap
okuduğunu müzikle eğitildiği ni kendi
okulunu kendinin yaptığını müthiş bir
aydınlanma dönemi yaşıyoruz ve tarım ve
kitap fakat
ne yazık ki gene O işte mithatpaşadan
sonra tarihten sonra Mustafa Kemal
Atatürk'ün bu aydınlanma döneminden
sonra güven süsleri de bazı çevreler
tarafından Aslında köyle Kent arasında
büyük bir uçurum sağlayacağım uçuruma
sebep olacağını söyleyerek
sonlandırılmış ne yazık ki Ama bu
Anadolu toprakları hem Tohumunda çok
bereketli tohumu çok güzel besliyor Aynı
zamanda da çok iyi insanlar yetiştiriyor
Benim yolum Mahmut Türkmen oğluyla
Bademler köyünde öğretmenlik yapmaya
başladım İlkokula başladığımda Muhtar ve
kitapla geldi hala Aydın Körler var
biliyorsunuz dedi ki sayın hocam bu dedi
bizim köyümüzün mühendisiydi Kooperatifi
var mıydı onun hayatı dır Allah rahmet
eylesin Mahmut Türkmenoğlu hayatı ve
ağlayarak okudum aynı köy
enstitülerindeki o dönemdeki gibi
tarımsal faaliyetleri bütün Türkiye'nin
her tarafına kendi yoldaşları ile
beraber yaymak için çalışmış Ama önce
kooperatifleşme yi kendi köyünde
sağlamak için bütün ileri gelenleri
Madenlerde topluyor bir kahvede ve
anlatıyor bizim diyor bir araya gelmemiz
lazım dayanışma içinde olmamız lazım ve
bu memleketi tarımla Kalkındırma mız
lazım yazık ki bir Güven Sorunu hep var
dayanışmada hep bir eksiklik Mahmut
diyorlar iyi hoş söylüyorsun da bir sana
nasıl güveneceğiz mesela diyorlar Gel
sen de akşam bu lokumları yesem biz
nereden bileceğiz günü o kadar bakmış
Mahmut'un söyledikleri Halbuki Mahmut
mühendis olmuş köyüne geri dönmüş ve
kalkınmaya inandığı için orada ama
vazgeçmemiş Mahmut ben oğlum köyde
bu pratik geçmeye başlattığı gibi
Seferihisar'da Urla'da Ödemiş'te bütün
İzmir'in ilçelerinde tarımsal Kalkınma
Kooperatifleri kurulması için destek
vermiş Yola Çıkmış sadece İzmir dememiş
Adana'ya gitmiş Edirne'ye gitmiş
Kastamonu'ya gitmiş Erzurum'a gitmiş
Türkiye'nin her tarafında kendine yoldaş
liderler bulmuş ve kooperatifleşme ne
kadar önemli olduğunu köylüye anlatmış
ve kurmuşlar Sonradan bir baktım Köy
Enstitüleri'nin kurulduğu yerlerde de
öyle bir çatı örgüt kurmuşlar ki
cocoklar kurulmuş 1960-70 olur
arasındaki bir çalışma bu 1971'de bütün
tarımsal Kalkınma ları üst çatıda
topluyor bu İzmir'de İzmir köy-koop hala
devam eden Manisa'da Adana'da Edirne'de
Kastamonu'da dediğim gibi köy
kuruluyor ve aynı zamanda da bu köy
coplarla beri
Ben Ankara'da 3-4 yıl sonra da çatısını
kuruyorlar 1970'lerde hatırlayanınız
varsa müthiş bir tarım ilerlemesi ve
Türkiye gerçekten köylüsüyle kendisiyle
bir arada yaşayabilen bir memlekette o
zaman kendi kendine yeten 7 ülkeden biri
olan bir memleket tek biz köy-koop işte
benim Bademler tarımsal Kalkınma
Kooperatifi buluşmam oradaki
öğretmenlikle oldu Madem ler okulundaki
öğretmenlik yaptığım günde blog onun
Aslında en önemli tarafının kadın var o
logoda kadını koymuşlar Aslında tarıma
baktığınız zaman kadının adı var mı var
Ben kooperatif başkanlarıyla konuştuğum
zaman kaç ortağınız var Başkanım diyoruz
Kırktan ediyorum kadınlar Tabii Hoca'nın
kadınlar Tarlada çalışıyor ama ortağımız
yönetimde kadın var mı E canım
Ne yapsın kadın yönetimi evde çocuk
bakacak yaşlı anne miz var
kayınvalideniz çok hasta şimdi bu kadın
1960'larda 70'lerden sonra kurulduktan
sonra 2014'e kadar o yönetim masasında
hiç olmamış Hatta İzmir'de olmadığı gibi
Ankara'da da olmamış burayı anlatarak
Aslında büyük hikaye ama döneceğim oraya
bir Seferihisar'da 2009'da bir hikaye
başlattık bir lider çıktı Kooperatifi
şimdi bize ama dedi kadınlar ne üretirse
Öncelikle kadınların ürettiklerini
satacağım kadınlar kooperatifleşmenin
bizim yanımıza gelsin onlara yerelde En
büyük desteği vereceğim bizim hazırla
tarımsal Kalkınma Kooperatifi'nin Biz
kadınlarla dedik ki nasıl erkekler bir
araya geliyor Sadece erkeklerin olduğu
partiler kuruyor O zaman bize kadınlarla
bir araya gelelim erkek ortak almayalım
pozitif ayrımcılığın alası
Ne yapalım O çatıda yapalım kadın ve
erkeğin bir araya geldiği bu köy topun
çatısında Biz de erkekleri ortak olarak
almayalım Ama şunu yapalım köy topun
İzmir'deki yönetimine girelim girdik ve
şöyle dedik bizde Bu yönetim açısından
olmak istiyoruz dedik O basamaklar o
kadar kolay çıkılmaz dediler bana
doğruymuş Aslında o kadar kolay
çıkılmıyor Muş çok ciddi bir yönetim
geçirdik bir adam azdır genel kurul
geçirdik tek kadın olarak 300 küsür
erkeğin bulunduğu bir salonda oy
beklemek biraz anne satılık da
olabilirdi ama hepsine buradan
şükranlarımı yolluyorum 2013-2014
seçimlerinde o salondaki erkekler bu
çatının altında yönetim masasında
kadınlarda olmalı dedi ve beni yönetimi
seçtiği gibi ben İzmir köy-koop birlikte
da aldım hepsini buradan çok teşekkür
ediyorum İzmir köy-koop başkanlığını
üstüne Ankara'da genel başkan doldum
Türkiye'deki bütün kooperatiflerin genel
başkanlığı Fakat ne yazık ki galiba
onlar da bir gaflete düştüklerini
anlayıp 6aylık süreçten sonra sen burada
olmasam iyi olur deyip Öyle bir seçim
yapıldı ki ben tekrar İzmir'e geri
döndüm Ama mücadele inandığım şeyde Biz
Seferihisar'da devam etmeye başladık
biliyorsunuz buz Seferihisar küçük bir
kalem içinde 250 tane hanenin olduğu
sıra cıkla çok meşhur oldu Herkes çok
iyi biliyor Biz ama o Sence hazırlanmak
için sefertası adında bir lokanta kurduk
bu sefer taşı lokantası'nda yemek yaptık
etrafı temizledik bulaşık yıkadık ama
dedi ki Kaymakam bey lütfen
misafirlerinizi bizde ayarlayın belediye
başkanına gittik lütfen misafirlerinizi
bizde ayarlayın ve bu sefer tasıyla
kazandığımız
ve hala bir dükkan tutmak için sefer
insanda dolaşmaya başladık Belediye
Başkanı bizim bu dolandı ımızı duymuş
çünkü para yetmiyor bizi makamda çağırdı
sizede için dükkan arıyorsunuz bize
sanıyoruz bize dükkan verecek size
internet üzerinden neden pazarlama
yapmıyorsunuz e-ticaret bu 2012 yıllarda
bize başka söylüyor mümkün değil
Başkanım tüzüğümüz de yok dedik bizim
sözümüz o zamanlarda 1960'dan kalma bir
tüzük Tüh Biz seferi pazar.com diye bir
sayfayı yerinde bize verdiği destekle
yani o sayfayı hazırlarken kurduk ve
gördüğünüz kadınlarla
bu Seferihisar'daki üretilen her ürünü
Türkiye'nin her yerine göndermeye
başladık sadece sefer tası da yaptığınız
yemekler değil aynı zamanda tarlamız
ürettiğimiz mandalinayı da otları da
Türkiye'nin her yerine gönderdik ve ve
Türkiye birincisi seçilen bir projeye
sahip olduk ve biz o seçildiniz
aldığımız ödül Binali Yıldırım'dan
almıştık kendisi O zaman başbakandı
Mehdi Eker da Tarım Bakanlığı the Ondan
sonra tüzük değişti Artık kooperatiflere
Ticaret yapabilir internet üzerinden
pazarlayabilirim diye bizim tüzüğümüz de
yazmaya başladı internet üzerinden
yaptığımız pazarlamanın sonunda Biz
aslında bütün bu yaptığımız çalışmaları
sığacıktaki kadınlara da Anlatmaya
başladık Gelin hep beraber kapımızın
önünde ürettiğimiz ne varsa hep beraber
satalım diye ve benim o zamanlar yanında
çalışan beraber Çocuklarımı da büyüttüm
Songül teyzem
ilk önce onu anlattım Songül teyzeciğim
dedim gel beraber şu pazara çıkalım ve
senin erken Neptün bak kadın yanındaki
de inanıyor Songül teyze tahmin
edersiniz ki ortadaki pembelik adına
vallahi kusura bakma dedi benim böreği
bir kim alacak Benim dolmama kim satacak
ama Songül teyzenin bu söyleminden sonra
yaklaşık bir yıl mücadele ettim Songül
teyze şu an benim yanımda işi bıraktı şu
Çünkü benden çok daha fazla pazarda para
kazandığını söyledi Sen de zaten dedi
Emekli oldum dedi Ben artık dedi pazarda
devam edebilirim çalışmalarıma Şimdi
Songül teyze şu an pazarda yanında iki
tane kadın çalıştırıyor aynı zamanda
kendine kartvizitte bastırmış
mi Evet sözcük pazarını biliyorsunuz
böyle onlarca kadın hikayesi
anlatabilirim ama zamanında olduğunu
söylüyorlar Suna hanım ulamışta kendi
halinde bir kadınken Geçen hafta geçen
sene Avrupa turnesinde en yeni geldi
Japonya'dan çekim teklifleri alıyor
Çünkü Suna hanım hikâyesinde Hepimizin
yaptığı gibi bir tek şeyi farklı söyledi
değişik bir hikaye sabun yapıyorsun
Hanım ama dedi ki ben sabunumu yaparken
yağmur sularını topluyorum kadar yoksa
herkes sabunu yapıyor ama Suna hanım o
kadar büyük bir değişim yaratık işim
Derya sarıl yağmur yağdığı zaman
sularımızı toplayalım da bizde sabunu
muzu yapalım diye hepsine Allah kolaylık
versin diyorum Bunlar sığacığın
Seferihisar'ın güzel kadınları ama bizim
en çok üstünde durduğumuz iyi Adil temiz
gıda yani yeraltı olmuş ben aslında
bugün sepetimde sizlere tohum geçirdim
Şu an Salonu
Şu an için kime ne kadar ne vereceğimi
bilmiyorum ve burada da Karakılçık
tohumları var bu tohumlar Anadolu'da
kurda kuşağı aşağıya serpilir Çünkü
doğal Sadece bizim değil bu Tohumdan
nasip inecek kurt da var kuş da var
bizim soframıza var Çok teşekkür
ediyorum